pronti oggi sto per riportare uno dei
video che vi successo maggiore degli
ultimi anni tecnicamente che è stato il
video dei dialetti cos'è il video dei
dialetti allora ve lo spiego siccome io
ho molti iscritti da proventi da tutta
italia un giorno mi è venuto in mente
una cosa ho detto vabbè dai facciamoci
mandare un vocale per tutte le persone
che mi seguono e dicono una frase nel
loro diretto che può essere pugliese
sicilia hard qualsiasi dialetto voi
parliate e poi ridicono quella frase in
un secondo vocale in italiano e mela
traducono ok io ascolto la prima frase
quindi sento il dialetto e provo a
tradurre che cosa mi hanno appena detto
poi se ci ho azzeccato lo scopro
ascoltando secondo vocale facciamo il
secondo episodio di dialetti aveva messo
la storia pochi minuti fa e mi sono
arrivati un miliardo di vocali partiamo
allora partiamo con raffaella dialetto
pugliese su mancini sheen era raffaele
hanno sbagliato a leggere cinesi ma
anche a massicci mag e mash machine
allora se dobbiamo darci in andiamocene
se non ce ne dobbiamo andare andiamoci
una roba del genere non proprio così ma
una roba del genere questo perché lo so
perché mio papà è pugliese mia mamma è
torinese quindi io minimo da mia nonna
pugliese
ho sentito cose quindi sappiamo dire
quello che vuol dire sotto comandare
andiamo saranno che mandare non andiamo
ecco l'unica cosa che azzerò di tutto il
video loro azzeccata all'inizio ottimo
perfetto andiamo lieto bresciano
[Musica]
comunque è un ghetto bresciano vuol dire
sarebbe guardala quella baccalà che in
quella casa l'altro ragazzi non mi
ricordo le frasi dello scorso episodio
quindi ci sta che magari succedono mi
dicano le stesse cose d'altre bisogno
non mi ricorderei comunque quindi in
avanti comunque lanka la mancata
napoletano chi lascia via vecchia pari a
salvo che le tasse non sa bachelet trova
capito un cazzo
chi lascia la via vecchia la strada
allora chi lascia la via vecchia per
quella nuova sa quello che lascia ma non
sa quello che trova tecnicamente cioè
chi rilascia la vecchia strada tesa
intraprendere una nuova sa quello che
lascia non sa a cosa va incontro
due a uno per farvi j signori grazie al
napoletano il pugliese mi hanno salvato
ben lieto di ancona attenzione 7p
intreccio come crede ma sto come credeva
store perché come il 3 devastò scusa del
3 debba stare cerchiamo il 3d bastoni
immagino che in italiano sia ti prende
ti intrecciato mentre di bastoni che
questo qui che però non è così
intrecciato come pensasse
mi ha dato morale martina grande marty
martina la conosco da tanto mi ha
mandato un locale in mezzo a tutti gli
iscritti e son riuscito a vederlo la
conosco questa ragazza da doppiatrice di
zelda e di anna baker infatti si è
sentito un po di cadenza di anna bayern
mista ho mandato una cassetta o me mi ha
dato un po di dialetto non la sentirai
mai la mia nota vocale mai con tutti i
messaggi che sarai ricevendo vado avanti
non c'è proprio la stessa già a martina
mi ricordo di tutte le ragazze con cui
parla lo teniamo
il mio non è un dialetto molto
particolare però c'è una frase che
dettava prende toscano stretto poi
sarebbe sati tanda tuma dindo che vorrà
mai dire sa e sa di duncan matino che
vorrà mai dire
non lo so se ti sente che fa la
doppiatrice comunque si senta anche
quando parlo con gianandrea parla quando
mi parla già dopo un po che mi parla di
comun
se mi si apre le rubriche parla di voi
come nei film
questa parlata molto chiara si capisce
tutto quello che dice quando parla un
doppiatore se ci fate caso hanno una
voce proprio toscano stretto che sarebbe
felice se tutto quello che dico non puoi
non capire cosa dice un doppiatore non
sentirmi dire scusami non ho capito a 1
che doppia mai comunque in dall dire
dove se dobbiamo andare
mando andiamo una roba del genere questo
vuol dire perché non lo so martina la
traduzione 16 andiamo mi devi dire dove
più o meno più o meno dai più e non
c'ero prima non c'era diciamo che non è
proprio non azzeccata in pieno
dai passano la martina ti prego ai
ragazzi ho chiesto anche a martina di
farci la voce di anna baker visto che
così gentile così ci chiuderà il video
questo video verrà chiuso con la voce di
una back nonché martina e la doppia
quindi anna chiuderà questo video nel
mentre ascoltiamo gli altri messaggi che
mi sono arrivati serena proviamo ad essi
dialetto calabrese quali sugar chiari du
pilu più agli sci più l'icona più vizi
il gatto più sia rizza al pelo cioè nel
senso sì poi fa i comodi suoi ma non
abbiamo capito che tra luce proprio il
modo di dire hai capito che pure non ha
davanti a questo che è più o meno quello
che ho detto io abbiamo martina
illuminaci ciao lorenzo da loro la frase
è cepile avevo porco è un porco a
recepire le bestemmie no a parte che non
sono anche di che dialetto emas
dimmelo scrivi dialèt penso sia non lo
so non ho capito niente e belli al
maiale cosa che diciamo quando tipo c'è
un'azione che si ripete quindi
sicuramente è sicuramente ho capito alto
accento max quanti calabresi stanno nel
mondo vocali e tutti i calabresi a big
family però non ho questa è l'unica
forse tra tutte che proprio non ho
capito un cazzo ma valore dall'inizio
alla fine però ok o giulia
una giulia siciliano sentiamo siciliano
questa voglio sentir dire a jovanotti
una volta si assiste successivi vuol
dire sì sì sì sì sì sì si è svegliato o
aurora dalla sardegna la sardegna mio
dio
sentiamo il sardo e h milo stampa naro
di olio allora fiacca mi vuol dire
khatami.lo stampa naro di yo yo yo yo
l'anime giorgio stampa nardi giorgio
sempre di giorgio si tratta marina che
ci manda a questo locale
ciao fa vi volevo dirti a mora brace
s'appiccica apache amor brush casa pc
che fa pace ma card ma come la pace
l'amore che significa amore vero
illecita e fa pace verace dove l'ho
tirato fuori io non farci caso la mia
voce raffreddore tranquilla marina
tranquillissima perché era tutto a posto
tranne la mia risposta non mi ha detto
poi che diretto è però da miriana
dall'abruzzo ci dice zamani strasicura
c'è la milella mai visto una figura che
c'ha na milan mi chi non s'è mai vista
una figura che punto interrogativo
gigante non ho capito niente
[Musica]
sempre esclusi non ho capito niente di
quello che ha detto niente dall'abruzzo
gori fino un cuoricino a temi realta non
capito come io capisco le donne nessuno
o milanese da ginevra ormai dovresti
saperlo è più o meno sancho anna la
barba bianca fan trova quel che le manca
san giovanni dalla barba bianca anni fa
trovare quello che mi manca e vai san
giovanni grazie è fatto trovare una
risposta giusta è la traduzione san
giovanni fame trovare e quello che sto
cercando praticamente anche se si
capisce
ciao nori ciao bella più o meno quello
che volete però non c'è mai la soluzione
precisa perfetta tipo come quando in
gioco esser provi a centrale ill.ma
distanza solo di qualche metro quindi
ragazzi questo era il virus i dialetti
ne farò sicuramente un altro mi
divertono un sacco perché lo so è come
se viaggiasse un po per tutta l'italia
in questa mezz'ora in cui registro è
stato molto bello partecipare se non
volete un altro io ringrazio tutti
quanti per aver partecipato e per aver
visto anche vide ovviamente è vi lascio
alla fine la chiusura di una vecchia
ciao sono anna anna baker in diretta e
stereo
questa è la tua cassetta e se non
condividerà il video la riceverai anche
tu